The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, we have the
clicker question up.
We're going to have another
clicker competition today.
The defending champs, there's
Darcy's recitation.
So, OK, let's just take 10
more seconds on this.
OK, not too bad, 74%.
So, in this problem, the trick
was just to look at the
equation and figure out what's
going on -- which element is
being reduced, and which
one is being oxidized.
So this is something that
you will be seeing on
the upcoming exam.
So we're going to talk about
that in a few minutes, but
first I want to answer the
question from last time.
So, first, let's just, I know
you've all been wondering
about how vitamin B12 is
reduced in the body.
So, let's take a look
at this now.
So, if everyone can quiet
down, let's get started.
So, vitamin B12 is reduced by
a protein that's called
flavodoxin.
And flavodoxin is a protein that
has a cofactor which is a
flavin, and that's also a
vitamin B, as it turns out,
they're both vitamin B's.
So, vitamin B12 has a redox
potential or a standard
reduction potential
of minus 0 .
5 2 6 volts, and that is
a very low number for a
biological system.
And flavodoxin has a potential
of minus 0.
2 3 volts.
So, which of these things is
a better reducing agent?
So, which thing, you want to
think about reducing agent,
which thing would prefer
to be oxidized and
reduce something else?
So, with the low negative
number, B12 is a better
reducing agent than flavodoxin,
and just based on
these numbers, vitamin B12
should be reducing flavodoxin,
not the other way around.
So, how does this work then?
So, in your body right now,
you have a version of a
flavodoxin protein, and you of
vitamin B12 attached to an
enzyme, methionine synthase, and
for that to be activated,
it needs to be reduced.
So how is this happening?
So, let's consider whether the
reduction of B12 by flavodoxin
is spontaneous.
It happens in your body so one
might think that it is.
But let's look at that.
So, we can look at it the same
way you've looked at all the
other systems, we're talking
about batteries, electric
chemical cells -- you can use
the same equations if it's a
biological system as you can
for any other system.
So we've seen this
equation before.
We've calculated changes in
the standard reduction
potential for a cell, and we
talked about e nought for
reduction minus the e nought for
oxidation, and we can use
that same equation.
So we can put it in in the
biological context.
The vitamin B12 is the thing
that's being reduced, and the
flavodoxin is the thing that's
being oxidized, that's the
reaction that happens.
So, we can plug those
values in.
So we have minus 0 .
5 2 6 volts, minus
a negative 0 .
2 3 volts, and if you
put those together,
you get minus 0 .
2 9 6 volts.
So is that going to be a
spontaneous reaction?
No, it's not going to be.
Your value for the e is
negative, which means what is
true about delta g?
Positive, so it won't
be spontaneous.
So, let's figure out how not
spontaneous it's going to be.
How much trouble
are we all in?
So we can use again, the same
equation that we used for
batteries that we've used in
this course -- just because
it's a biological system,
doesn't mean the equation
doesn't hold.
So our equation for delta g
nought minus n, the number of
moles of electrons times
Faraday's constant times the
change in the standard
potential.
So we can plug it in.
I can tell you it's a one
electron process -- flavodoxin
puts one electron into vitamin
B12, so we have minus 1 times
Faraday's constant times the
cell potential difference you
just measured, which
is minus 0 .
2 9 6, and if you multiply those
out, then you get 28 .
6 kilojoules per
mole positive.
That is a very big value --
that's not spontaneous and
it's not a small number for
a biological system.
So, why don't we all have
heart disease and
megaloblastic anemia?
Those are problems associated
when this particular enzyme is
not functioning.
So, what happens in this system
is what happens in a
number of biological systems.
How do you drive something
forward that is not
spontaneous?
And what you can do is put
energy into the system to
drive that non-spontaneous
reaction.
And in this case, the energy
that's put into the system is
from a molecule called
s adenosylmethionine.
And the cleavage of s
adenosylmethionine has a delta
g nought of negative 37 .
6 kilojoules per mole.
So it's more favorable than
the reduction of B12 is
unfavorable, and so this
drives this system.
So, s adenosylmethionine is your
friend, it helps in the
body for B12 to be reduced
so that you can
function and be healthy.
So, many biological systems
work like this.
So what have we been calling
something, a cell, in which an
unfavorable reaction is driven
by applying some kind of
energy or current, what
do we call that?
Two types of cells
we mentioned.
One that has a favorable, it
has a spontaneous reaction.
A cell that has a spontaneous
reaction is called what?
Galvanic.
And the other kind is called?
Yup.
So, electrolitic cell.
So this is sort of the
biological equivalent of an
electrolitic cell where you
have s adenosylmethionine
cleavage coupled to an
unfavorable reaction to drive
that reduction of B12
by flavodoxin.
And B12 has such a low
potential, that there really
isn't anything else that
can reduce it.
It has one of the lowest
potentials known in a
biological system, so nature
said, OK, well, we're not
going to make something with a
lower potential to do this
chemistry, we'll have something
else with a higher
potential, but will drive the
reaction because it's going to
be non-spontaneous.
So that's how this works.
So, today there's a long list
of topics, all of these are
pretty short and basically
constitute the introductory
material in this unit.
And we've jumped ahead,
this is in chapter 16.
So, I really like transition
metals, because I am a fan of
metals that are involved in
biological systems. So, I just
thought as part of chemistry, I
just want to sort of review
the kind of basic areas of
chemistry for a minute.
This is not in your handout, but
just so you sort of think
about what are all parts
of chemistry.
There is organic chemistry --
does anyone know what organic
chemistry concerns itself with?
Carbon.
And then what we have known
as inorganic chemistry.
Anyone know what that is?
Not carbon.
So, a lot of people who are
inorganic chemists study
transition metals, but
it's basically other
things besides carbon.
And then one of the areas that
I like is bioinorganic
chemistry, and these
are people who
study metals in biology.
So, people who study metals in
biology, and we're also kind
of referred to as, we're
sort of in a club,
which we call the MIB.
So, some of you -- and Will
Smith did a disservice --
people now associate this with
hunting aliens, but in fact,
people who are in MIB are
associated with hunting for
metal ions in biological
cells.
So this is sort of
the true MIB.
And in an honor of this
discussion today, I am wearing
a teeshirt from one
of our meetings.
This is from the International
Congress on Bioinorganic
Chemistry, which we
refer to as ICBIC.
And you notice that the clever
people who made this teeshirt
used the B from the bioinorganic
to make B12,
which is a very popular
vitamin in the
bioinorganic community.
So, metals in biology.
Carbon, carbon's a good
thing, amino acids are
good, I like proteins.
But often, when you take a
metal and attach it to a
protein, that protein can do
really cool chemistry --
really need oxidation
reduction chemistry.
So, here is part of the periodic
table that includes
many of these transition metals
that we're going to be
talking about.
And things that are in orange
here are metals that are very
important biologically.
Some of the things that are in
grey here are metals that are
used as probes or as drugs in
biological systems, and some
could be both.
So, when you add a metal to a
protein you can do cool stuff.
What can you do?
Well, you can split nitrogen.
You learned that the triple
bond of nitrogen is pretty
hard to break, but metals
in proteins can do it.
You've heard of hydrogen fuel
cells and things like that.
There's a protein called
hydrogenase that uses metals
to do chemistry with hydrogen.
You could you radical
based chemistry.
You can do a lot of really great
things when you have a
protein that has
a metal in it.
So, let me introduce you to
some of the concepts and
terminology involved in this, so
we're going to have a metal
and the metal's going to
be bound to stuff.
So, one of the great features of
transition metals is their
ability to form complexes with
small molecules or ions.
They also, this applies to a
protein system in the case
that instead of small molecules,
you have amino
acids of proteins it can also
form complexes with.
So, the way that they do this is
metals have often, they can
attract electron density,
usually a lone pair of
electrons from another atom, and
so they can form what are
called these coordination
complexes.
So, now we're going to review
for a minute, donor atoms,
they're called ligands, and we
can think about something that
we learned when we talked about
acids and bases, our
more broad definition.
So, donor atoms are ligands,
and ligands are what?
Lewis acids or Lewis bases,
and what do they do?
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
So most of you thought donor
atoms -- the answers that had
donate electrons did better,
so that was good reading of
the question, but they
are Lewis bases.
So Lewis bases donate
electron pairs.
So, here's some examples that
you will see of ligands that
we'll be talking about
in this unit.
You will become very familiar
with some of these as you work
problems. So they're typically
donating one
lone pair of electrons.
So, acceptor atoms are the
transition metals themselves,
and so the transition metals are
acting as Lewis acids, and
so then they would be
accepting those
lone pairs of electrons.
So, you can think about
coordination complexes as
Lewis acids and Lewis bases,
or acceptor atoms and donor
ligands or donor atoms. So
here are some examples of
transition metals that we're
going to see, so it's that
sort of d-block of the periodic
table that we'll
become very familiar
with in this unit.
So, then when you take your
acceptor atom and your donor
atom and you put them together,
you get what is
known as coordination
complexes.
So, coordination complex is just
the metal or the Lewis
acid surrounded by the ligands,
or the Lewis bases or
the donor atoms.
And here is an example of
a coordination complex.
We have metal, we have cobalt
in the middle, and it's
surrounded by a series
of ligands, and
these are n h 3 ligands.
And so then our cobalt in the
center, our metal, is the
Lewis acid, and it's going
to be the acceptor atom.
And the n h 3 groups are our
Lewis bases, they're donor
atoms, see it's written with
those two electrons there,
that they're sharing their
electrons with the cobalt
forming this coordination
complex.
And in this scheme, we have
the bonds are just these
straight lines are in the plane,
the thick bonds coming
out are coming out toward you,
and the dashed lines going
back are going back into
the screen here.
So, let's talk about a couple
of definitions here.
We have something called
coordination number or CN
number, and this is simply
the number of ligands
bonded to the metal.
So the number is six, there
is six ligands.
Typically, the numbers will
range for these coordination
complexes to two to 12, with
six being the most common.
So, here is some notation.
If you see this picture, you
should be able to write a
notation for it.
And within a bracket, you would
write cobalt, and then
you have your n h 3, six of
them, so you put that in a
bracket and indicate that
there's six n h 3 groups.
Then you have this overall
bracket here
with a charge up above.
And so over here, we have this
little bracket plus 3, that
means that this whole
coordination complex has a
charge of plus 3.
Because it has a positive
charge, sometimes coordination
complexes are associated
with counter ions.
So, you might see three chloride
minus 1 ions around
to counter that charge.
And if you did, you would see
the three chlorides on the
outside of the bracket.
So things inside of the
bracket are actually
coordinated to the metal, things
outside the bracket are
counter ions.
And so that would be how you
would translate that
particular notation.
All right, so, we're back
to geometry again.
As I said, everything you learn
in this course, we're
going to use again.
So, if you're forgetting some
material from units 1 and 2,
this would be a good time
to review those.
So, if we have this coordination
number of six
things around, what kind of
geometry are we going to have?
All right, 10 seconds.
Yup, so we have octahedral
geometry.
And here is an example of
our octahedral geometry.
So, let's just quickly run
through the rest of these.
You can yell out the answers,
either looking at your handout
or not looking at
your handout.
The next one over here,
what is it?
Right, trigonal bipyramidal.
For a c n number of five, we
have another option shown over
here, what's that one called?
Square pyramidal.
For c n numbers of four, there's
two things that you'll
commonly see, what's the
first one called?
Square planar.
The second one?
Tetrahedral.
For c n number of three, what's
that geometry called?
Trigonal planar.
And c n of two, only
one option.
Linear.
All right, so let's just review
the angles as well,
those are not in your handouts,
but you can yell
those out as well.
So what angle do we have in
an octahedral system?
90.
There are two angles involved
if we have trigonal
bipyramidal.
What's the angle from the
axial to the equatorial?
STUDENT: 90.
PROFESSOR: And what's the angle
from one equatorial atom
to another equatorial atom?
So, we have 90 and 120.
What about in our square
pyramidal system, what are the
angles here?
90.
What about square planar?
Tetrahedral?
Let's try that again with
more enthusiasm.
Awesome, 109 .
5.
Trigonal planar?
120.
And finally, linear.
180.
So, we're going to use this
information again in this
unit, and of course, it'll be
on the final when we're
talking about Lewis structures
and hybridization and other
things as well.
So this comes back in several
times, vsper theory, you have
this several times.
OK.
So, another term that you hear
a lot when people are talking
about coordination complexes
is what's
called the chelate effect.
So, ligands that bind to a metal
at one point are called
unidentate or monodentate, and
that's from dent, which is
tooth, so one tooth.
Now, if a ligand attaches with
two or more points of
attachment, it can be called
a chelating ligand.
And this comes from the
Greek, chele is claw.
So, if it's attaching with
more than one point of
attachment, if the ligand is
grabbing on, it's like a claw
and that's called a chelate.
So, if you have two points
of attachment,
that's called bidentate.
And even if you've never had
a unit on transition metals
before, I bet that you can
answer this without me even
telling you.
What do you think tridentate
might be?
Three.
Tetradentate?
Four.
Hexadentate?
Six.
So sometimes this would be a
little question on the final.
Please don't get this wrong,
this is my gift to you, right,
you knew it even before
I taught it.
So, this should be something
that you can definitely get a
couple extra points
on on the final.
All right, so, chelates bind
with more than one point of
attachment, and metal chelates
are unusually stable.
And this property is due to
favorable and tropic factor,
so we're back to entropy, we're
back to thermodynamics.
And this has to do with the fact
that when a chelate binds
a metal, it releases a lot of
water, and that makes the
chelate pretty stable.
So, let me give you some
examples of chelates, and then
we're going to come back
and think about the
chelate effect again.
Of course, you knew it, vitamin
B12 has a chelating
ligand associated with it.
So, cobalt is in the middle of
vitamin B12, and it has a ring
system around it.
And the ring system has these
nitrogens, the nitrogens are
the donor ligands to the cobalt,
and so this ring
system is attaching at four
points, so it's a
tetradentate ligand.
There's also two other ligands
attached to vitamin B12,
there's an upper ligand shown
here, which is 5 prime
deoxyadenosine, and a bottom
ligand, which is a
dimethylbenzamitisol ligand.
So, let's take a look, this is
the cartoon, but let's look at
another model for this here.
So, we have a ring system, we
have this upper ligand, and
then a lower ligand down here.
And so, the middle ring system
is a tetradentate chelate.
Overall, at the cobalt
metal, what is the
geometry of this system?
It's octahedral, right.
So we have this sort of square,
the middle part is
square planar, but the two upper
and lower ligands make
the whole thing an octahedral
system.
So this is an example
of a naturally
occurring chelated complex.
So, this structure is
actually fairly
complicated for a vitamin.
It's one of the most complex
vitamins that's known, and I
thought I'd just mention just
a moment of history.
So, this structure was
determined by Dorothy Hodgkin
who was a crystalographer
in England.
And she started working on this
in the late 1940's, and
people told her she was crazy,
that something this large
could never be solved by these
x-ray defraction techniques.
And, of course, now people are
solving today's structures of
things like the ribosomes.
So, we've come a long way
with crystallography.
But she was one of the first
true believers that x-ray
crystallography was a
powerful technique.
And so, she went ahead, despite
what everyone said,
and determined this structure.
And for this work and for some
other things, she was awarded
a Nobel Prize.
So, this was a really
significant contribution in
the early 1950's and
late 1940's.
She had graduate students
that she inspired.
Some of them went on to become
famous crystalographers.
Other ones were not
so successful --
crystallography's hard and
it's not for everyone.
She was actually known also,
Dorothy was, for her work in
the third world and her liberal
politics, but one of
her graduate students did not
agree with her politics, but
they were still friends.
So this is just a message that
as you go through your career,
Margaret Thatcher who is a
graduate student of Dorothy
Hodgkins, couldn't quite cut it
as a crystalographer, but
for some people, you haven't
found your true thing, and she
was able to find another
job, so I'm told.
So, just remember that if you're
not good at one thing,
there's something else
out there that you
might be good at.
So, let me give you a second
example of a chelate.
This molecule is
known as EDTA.
So this ligand has six points
that it can attach to a metal.
So, it is six atoms the can
serve as these donor ligands.
So, we have one up here, have
the little electrons and the
oxygen, another oxygen down
here, nitrogen, nitrogen,
another oxygen, another
oxygen.
So all of those six points can
coordinate to a metal.
So here again is the free EDTA,
and here's a structure
of EDTA bound to a metal, the
metal is abbreviated m.
So, why don't you tell me what
the geometry is of that metal?
All right, let's take only
10 more seconds.
Hoping for 90, we're getting
close, maybe
by the end of today.
All right, yeah, so it's
octahedral geometry.
So we have upper ligands and
a lower ligand, two ligands
coming out, two ligands going
back, and it's also a
hexadentate complex.
So we see we're coordinated
with the oxygen in red,
nitrogen in blue, around to the
other nitrogen in blue,
another nitrogen in purple,
another nitrogen up here in
green and in blue.
So, EDTA, when EDTA binds to a
metal, it forms a very stable
metal complex.
And the reason for this
is that chelate
effect, and it's entropy.
So if we look, metals are often
coordinated by waters if
they're just is solution.
But if you bind one molecule
of EDTA to the metal, it'll
take all of those six sites,
displacing all
of these six waters.
So here, on this side, you
have one thing free in
solution, and over here you have
six things that are free.
So that's entrotropically
favorable, you have more
entropy when you have
lots of more free
things floating around.
So this has greater entropy.
So, the chelate effect, then,
has to do with entropic
effect, that when you're binding
a metal with multiple
points of attachments,
it's releasing water.
So these are very stable.
And so, because of this
stability, they have a lot of
important uses.
What is one use you can think
of that you might have for
such a thing?
When might you want to chelate
a metal out -- get metal out
of something pretty quickly.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can purify out a metal
out of water with this.
What about rushing to the
emergency room with something?
Yeah, lead poisoning, yup.
So, sometimes you might want to
just purify your water, you
might be happy with that, other
times you might really
want to have that metal out.
So, every emergency room in
the United States, and
probably mostly around the
world, will have EDTA on hand
in case someone comes in
with lead poisoning.
Do you know who's at the most
risk for lead poisoning, at
least in this country?
Kids.
And what do they do they gives
them lead poisoning?
Lead paint, yeah.
So, I don't know, most of you
are probably living on campus,
but if any of you move off
campus, and some people who
are living maybe across the
river in fraternity houses,
those buildings are old and they
have had lead paint in at
some point or another.
So this is a big problem,
actually, in the Boston area.
So, if you have any toddlers
visiting you, you might want
to make sure they're not eating
paint chips off any
window sill or anything
like that.
Or if you do, have some
EDTA on hand.
All right, one other thing, some
of you, once you start
studying chemistry, it's always
fun/scary to start
reading the ingredients
on food packages.
But you will discover that some
food that you eat will
say as an ingredient EDTA
added for freshness.
So, bacteria and fungi and
things like that need metals
for growth, metals are very
important for life, and so you
add a little EDTA and it
prevents things from growing
on your food.
So that's added for freshness.
So you'll see it in food.
Another use that occasionally I
find MIT students are not as
familiar with is in cleaning
bathtubs, so you want to
chelate out the calcium in
tub scum, and that's a
good use for EDTA.
So, I always like to mention
how freshman chemistry
information can make
you a lot of money.
So, I thought I'd tell you a
little story about a man named
Robert Black.
So one day, I think it might
have been a little before
Thanksgiving, Mrs. Robert Black,
I don't know her first
name, said to her husband,
"We're having company, how
about you go clean the bathtub?"
Apparently, Robert
Black's wife had never mentioned
this to him before,
and he had, in fact, never
cleaned a bathtub.
Also, I think that Robert
Black's wife was tired of
cleaning the bathtub, and
perhaps, had not done it for,
say, a very long time.
So, Robert Black went in there
and tried to scrub off the
scum, and it was actually really
challenging and he was
very frustrating, and he said,
"I never want to do that
again."
So, he went and developed a
product, a shower cleaner,
that had all the ingredients of
the shower cleaners he was
using, except that he advertised
it slightly
differently, and he said "Every
time you shower, just
spray a little bit on and you'll
never have to really
scrub again." because this will
take care of it and avoid
scrubbing in the future, so a
little bit of spraying after
each shower avoids these
problems. And the ingredients
he had in were all typical
ingredients, including
chelating agents.
You need a surfactant to break
up the water beads, and
alcohol to get rid of the oily
stuff, and the chelating agent
for the calcium in
the tub scum.
And the one he actually
used is EDTA.
So, as a result of a wife saying
to her husband, it's
your turn to clean the tub,
they now make $70 million
dollars annually.
So, I think this is a lesson
that we can learn in many ways
that cleaning the tub is
something that everyone should
do at some point in their life,
and that the simple
things you learn in freshman
chemistry can, if applied
correctly, make you
a lot of money.
And I just want to encourage
you, again, that anything that
I teach you that you use to
make a lot of money, I'll
remind you that I am perfectly
willing to have a
cut of any of that.
So, just something
to keep in mind.
So, one more thing that you
might have heard for EDTA.
Have any of you heard, perhaps,
maybe watching
television or a movie,
about a use for EDTA?
Have any of you, perhaps, seen
a movie called Blade?
How many of you have
seen this?
Not very many people.
Hmm, I think we're going to
have a separate course in
vampire movies and TV. Anyway,
Blade fights vampires, and
they have a special gun, and the
special gun has cartridges
-- cartridges are shown here.
And the cartridges have in them
-- anyone want to guess?
EDTA, yes.
And the idea behind it, if you
shoot at a vampire, the
vampire turns instantaneously
to dust, and the idea behind
it is that vampires drink blood,
blood has what in it?
Iron.
What chelates iron?
EDTA.
And, therefore, if you chelate
the iron out of blood, and a
vampire's mostly blood, it just
instantaneously turns to
dust. So, actually, as chemistry
goes, it's kind of
cool, yeah.
So, that's the final use that
I am aware of for EDTA.
Some of you may encounter
some more.
All right, so coordination
complexes.
Some of them can have isomers.
They can have geometric
isomers.
And geometric isomers can have
vastly different properties.
And if you're interested in
biochemistry, this is
something that you'll be
interested in, because this
can be very important in
biological systems.
So, let me tell you about a
coordination complex that has
platinum at the center, it has
two ammonia ligands and two
chloride ligands, and it has two
ways that you can do it.
So, you can either put the
ammonia ligands on different
sides or you can put them
on the same side.
So, here we have two nitrogen
ligands over here, and I have
these here.
So, on one side, you have the
two nitrogen ligands, on the
other side two chlorides, or we
can have a transarrangement
where they're across
from each other.
So you see, there's 2 different
ways to do it, on
the same side or
sort of across.
So, cis or trans.
Cisplatin is a potent
anti-cancer drug, transplatin
has no use that anyone's
been able to detect.
So it's the exact same
composition, but a different
arrangement of the
atoms coordinated
to the central metal.
So, why should it make a
difference, they have the same
ingredients, why should one be
a potent anti-cancer drug and
the other one be useless?
Well, it's because of how it
interacts in the body.
And so, one of the people who
have spent a lot of their
career studying cisplatin is
Professor Steve Lippard, who's
in the Chemistry Department
here, and he has determined
x-ray structures looking at
this, and done a number of
other studies.
And so, here is a little cartoon
of cisplatin bound to
DNA, so the chlorides are
displaced when it binds, and
so they need to be on the same
side, otherwise it's
not going to work.
And when cisplatin binds to
DNA, then this will act to
kill the cancer cells.
So, the chlorides both need to
be on the same side so a
combined DNA.
If they're on other sides,
that's not going to interact
with DNA, and so it doesn't
have any known function.
So, geometric isomers, same
composition, but in different
arrangements can have vastly
different properties.
So you can have what are called
optical isomers or
enantiomers, and so these can
our mirror images of each
other, but they're not
superimposable.
And so, when you have a mirror
image like this, it's called a
chiral molecule, and this is a
term that you'll hear a lot
when you take organic
chemistry.
So, I have two mirror images up
here, so these are mirror
images, so the mirror plane is
between these molecules.
But these molecules may look
the same in the mirror, but
they're non-superimposable.
So, they are, in fact, different
molecules, and they
can have different properties
in a chiral environment.
What do I mean by a chiral
environment?
Well, the human body, for
example, is a chiral
environment.
So that's why a lot of drugs,
people are wanting to make
just one enantimer of the drug
and not the other, one
enantiomer can have good
properties, the
other one may not.
All right, so let's do some
d-electron counting.
This is the final thing we
need to talk about in
coordination complexes.
So we're going to refer to a
thing called the d-electron
count of the metal, which just
has to do with a group number
from the periodic table minus
the oxidation number of the
metal, is going to tell us
the d-electron count.
So, if you haven't learned how
to do oxidation numbers yet,
you need to know that for exam
3, and you need to know that
for this unit.
So, let's look at a few examples
of this, and we'll
put up our friend, the
periodic table.
So let's look at the complex
that we saw on the first page
where we had -- in the beginning
of today's lecture
where we had cobalts with
six n h 3 ligands in a
coordination complex that
had a charge of plus 3.
So here, we need to figure out
the oxidation number of the
cobalt, and for this particular
group, the overall
charge of that is 0.
We have three hydrogens at plus
1, and we also have a
nitrogen at minus 1.
And so, overall that
charge is 0.
So we have six things of 0, and
what does that leave for
our cobalt charge?
Plus 3.
Because overall, it now
has to equal plus 3.
So, then our d count for our
electrons is going to be the
group number.
And for cobalt, what's
the group number?
9.
So minus 3 is 6, so this cobalt
in this complex is
what's called a d 6 system.
All right, let's look at a
couple other examples here.
Let's look at nickel with
carbon monoxide
ligands, four of them.
What would nickel
be in this case?
Someone said zero.
That's right.
So this is zero, and
nickel is zero, the
overall charge is zero.
So, our oxidation number
here is 0.
So, our d count here, what's the
group number for nickel?
10.
10 minus 0 is 10.
So we have a d 10 system.
So, I'm going to write another
example down and you're going
to tell me the answer to this
one as a clicker question.
So we have cobalt, two waters
-- three waters -- that's
actually a mistake.
It should be two.
Two waters, because it's going
to be six things -- this is
not some kind of bizzaro
seven complex.
So here's the correct, cobalt,
two waters, one ammonia, and
three chlorides with an overall
charge of minus 1.
All right, let's just take 10
seconds, since we're running
out of time.
So that's right, we should have
a charge of plus 2 here.
This is zero, 0 minus 3, overall
minus 1, so we have a
plus 2 state.
We have 9 minus 2, which is
7, and it's a d 7 system.